hey guys it is the 30th of March today
my name is Jeff and you are watching
games but new Xbox boss Phil Spencer has
confirmed two new features that are set
to arrive on Xbox one with the upcoming
Windows 10 anniversary update one such
feature is background music which will
let you listen to music while playing
games that feature is already available
on xbox 360 and playstation 4 through
Sony's partnership with music streaming
giant Spotify if listening to tunes
while grinding division levels doesn't
appeal to you Microsoft are also adding
in Cortana their Serie ask digital
assistant you'll be able to ask her
about anything and just like on Windows
10 and hopefully she'll hear you
understand you and offer up a half
helpful answer but who can really say
with the digital assistant you will need
a connect if you want to chat to other
Spencer add a bit microsoft will
announce more anniversary features at e3
in june so the update is likely still a
ways up more details about rocket
league's new basketball mode hoops have
been announced the official rocket
league twitter account reveals that the
mode is set to arrive in april they also
tacked on a gift where you can check out
a stunning play from one competitor in
the new doghouse arena develop a psionic
added that they have figured out xbox
one and ps4 cross-platform play but the
publishers still need to get on board
with the feature to facilitate it a
reported marketing survey for Mass
Effect Andromeda have made its way onto
reddit and neogaf describing what may be
some features of the upcoming
installment one of the survey slides
gives us a pretty good overview of the
game it reads Mass Effect Andromeda
takes players to the Andromeda galaxy
are beyond the Milky Way where players
will lead the fight for a new home in
hostile territory where we are the
aliens opposed by a deadly indigenous
race content on stopping us the
depiction also suggests that the game
will feature a seamless open-world
galaxy d progression and customization
systems and
player choices another slide reveals
that Andromeda's story will include a
massive interplanetary battle where
you'll be fighting for all of humanity
again Andromeda was scheduled to arrive
this holiday but reports have suggested
it could be pushed back to 2017 I own a
downy Matt comment section what you want
to see from Mass Effect Andromeda and be
sure to head to gamespot will we've got
stories on Far Cry primal survival mode
and free playstation plus games let me
know down in that comment section what
you cared about today and be sure to
come by same time tomorrow for a bunch
more news